Luke and Tom here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and today we're in Japan
and we're trying every single Japanese
soda that we can are you excited Tommy
yeah all right
let's get started with Tommy's favorite
this is ramen a soda this is one that
Tommy's been wanting to try forever open
this up and you get this little plunger
here take the plunger out and it pushes
this marble that's blocking the hole
like a cork pushes it down into the
bottle and then there's this marble
sitting in there so you can see this
marble marble floating around
absolutely
traditional original flavor romani
tastes a little bit like a sprite but
different definitely different but it's
the closest thing to compare - are you
enjoying that
so we drink the romani and Tommy wants
the marble out so go and unscrew that
and then give it a good and there you go
there's Tommy should we get mommy a
drink let's see we can get Pocari sweat
um cattle pizza you just get water
well you can get a ginger ale with extra
ginger I Mitsui cider or apple flavored
or a normally Suicider there's some
extra money in there
all right so this is Pocari sweat though
it's your ion supply drink but what does
it taste it's taste like nothing else
it's it's subtle flavor it's not as
strong yeah very different
you like it yeah Bugatti swittel is
probably one of my favorite like enter
like sports drinks you know you're
dehydrated when it's all hot humid love
it
like robbery yeah you know what I've got
a peach juicer an Aquarius which one do
you want - sorry go for it tell me what
you think of it mmm that is good okay
yeah it's good I need the peach with a
little better but is it both good so
this is Aquarius is the first Japanese
drink I ever had had it on the plane
ride to Japan my first time in Japan
it tastes a lot like Pocari sweat the
sports drink vacati sweat
Aquarius and another drink called sport
Jeep all tastes really similar it's
kinda like Gatorade and Powerade you
want a Pikachu soda hit the blue button
and under Pikachu it's a Pokemon carried
in apple juice thread
yeah it's carrot apple and orange juice
yeah okay here we go we got melon cider
plastic original me to eat cider so me -
yeah means three arrows so you can see
their logo and Mitsubishi the car needs
three diamond and a similar meteor cider
is kind of like 7up
but a little bit more fruity medical or
dingo milk and orange I think is what
that says a little bit Tommy is going to
have a 7-up good taste just like this
have it up maybe a little bit sweeter
okay we're gonna try some CC lemon here
I'm gonna try as Odinga soda with pulp
which do you want lemonade or lemons
orange soda there you go there's
lemonade Odinga
soda this it's like busy carbonated
orange juice have a taste
carbonated lemonade
I'm gonna tell you the melon pop okay we
get a lemon CC for Tommy and I'm gonna
try the Sun Tony melon pop 11 cc
all right we're gonna try the melon pot
here
that's good fight melon flavor it's good
Tommy's here on the lookout for another
vending machine that boy loves him some
soda and I don't blame him
where'd your pan put it in there another
brown one I want to try something I
haven't tried before all right we're
gonna try some cooties told me it's all
here this is actually it's sweeter it's
it's there's like no pulp in it it's not
like normal tomato juice which is really
thick this is just like tomato flavored
water almost but there's something else
something kind of sweet in it all right
get the peach one all right
here we are little sucker castle and
we're having some cootie pizza
goodbye oh that's fabulous oh that's
amazing yeah that was it's just like
peach juice with pulp in it
it's really good the castle was awesome
we're gonna have a meeting gee soda here
see what else they got
cheering sports or what's this aminoacyl
I all right we're gonna try a Meno
supply whatever that is
what is that it's almost like water with
a slight hint of strawberry bubble gum
hmm all right we got your cult meter
juice soda tastes a little bit like
carbonated kalpas you like that one
good good you can't but so if you're in
Japan one thing you end up drinking a
lot of is movie cha it's an herbal tea
made from like roasted wheat or barley
or something like that it's one of those
things where most people don't like it
when they first try it but after you
drink in a bunch you really get into it
I love it but I've heard it described as
drinking the water out of an ashtray
that's been left out in the rain but
we're gonna give Tommy some see what he
thinks
I mean what do you think of the movie
Chuck you like it I do it I don't do you
want some more yeah
Mui cha doesn't have a very strong taste
it's kind of a weak flavor at first but
then it has this kind of burnt
aftertaste that some people hate and
some people love and I like it
all right mom's gonna get a drink here
why don't you
once you pick someone TV in sports or
lemon squash I don't know I've never had
it yes it looks like a cord I had that
one it was okay
tastes like Aquarius in Picardy sweat
q all right we'll try some
hmm oh that's really delicious apple
juice
oh that's good for
that is really good apple juice I got a
big pile of ten cent coins here you need
to see what we can get rid of here
all right we've got peach Kalfas in goun
goun yogurt all googoo yogurt on a
psychic home
okay so goun goun yogurt Oh tastes like
watery probiotic yogurt drinks look why
like help us but that's okay
you know you're like what does it taste
like Pete's compass yeah there you go
pizzicato pieces yeah it's actually
pretty good good all right guys here we
are last drink of the trip I think I'm
gonna try some eye on water whatever
that is and Tommy's gonna try some apple
juice here okay you want to see what the
ion water tastes like yeah it tastes it
it tastes like wheat watery the cloudy
sweat ball well hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video of us testing all the
different soft drinks in Japan if you
guys liked this video don't forget to if
you like this video don't forget to
check out our 2018 World Tour where we
spent five weeks traveling all over Asia
and North America and having all sorts
of great adventures it's a twelve part
series and is absolutely amazing so
don't forget to click Subscribe for more
adventures from the outdoor boys YouTube
channel and click the link below to see
more videos from this trip